[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
one of my best friends got [ __ ] up one
time and he started talking about asian
people we never even seen any asians in
our life
and he started your life knowing i guess
maybe like in a past life he might have
known some asians you know and so he
starts bringing up their names bro and
knowing him and knowing [ __ ] about him
on this mattress in this house
and i'm like [ __ ] dude you're [ __ ] up
bro i'm leaving right so apparently i'm
the kind of friend that when your friend
is at his worst
you [ __ ] leave bro
because he's talking about chinese
people yeah i've never met chinese we've
never known any so what is he saying
he's just saying like hey you remember
[ __ ] like sin like you remember
[ __ ] son lamb bro he was there for us
you know and all this [ __ ] i'm like son
lamb bro we don't know him dude you know
he was [ __ ] like talking about
dorothy dorothy dorothy you know we
didn't know any asians bro and i'm like
i gotta get away from where you came
from when you grew up there was no
asians in that neighborhood not when you
were there now there's probably four
yeah yeah
dude we had a woman named dot wall was
i'm gonna rob a bus driver
that wall dude seven letters baby that's
what she used to say that was her motto
after she say her name seven letters
baby beat that that's what you would say
and we had a man named milford king who
wore no shirt two days he wore no shirt
and [ __ ] drove us to school big guy
milford that's cool he was wild i saw
him [ __ ] throw a senior citizen into
a ditch fire and the man died and that
was [ __ ] pretty bizarre why he threw
a senior citizen and they were fighting
fire they were fighting next to a ditch
fire
yeah dude if you ever pay my fries bro
game of thrones gary polito and gary
polito came off that fire bro came out
that fire on fire still swinging at
milford he was a hunt he was maybe 200
italian dude was the fire in the
italians can swing and [ __ ] burn at
the same time
and they were fighting by the ditch
because they both had their shirts off
and it was cold out so you want to be
close to you want to stay warm while you
fight that was their whole idea was the
ditch just filled with like burning
senior citizens that he tossed in there
body fire of milford's victims just
leaves dude and probably some
recyclables but this is before the head
recycles this is back when you could
[ __ ] burn whatever dude and let's
just let the moon [ __ ] take a hit off
your [ __ ] noxious gas
[ __ ] lift up yeah let a [ __ ] bird
get hit off this [ __ ] melting uh
off this burning milk just [ __ ] it just
throw the jugs in there or whatever and
you would smell it you just just smell
it on the wind [ __ ] yeah trash [ __ ] i
could be a wreck dude the original
viagra dude yeah it still happens
smelling fossil fuels burn in the
distance dude i'll come right now bro if
i don't want a penis in my mouth it's
not going in amen bro i've been saying
that my whole life dude
this is i know you have and that's
[ __ ] life dude so i can relate to
that 100
like i really can't
what's going on you hear something in
here
it is cool it's like a hype thing
oh it's wrestling it's joe rogan is it
yeah
what
we're next door
in in the back of all of our heads of
america right now
we're in i wouldn't be surprised if
rogan did implant a chip and or i know
he's just secretly just like what's up
man this high five and then chip into
your [ __ ] hand
and he just watches over in his [ __ ]
icicle but he just sits in nude yeah i'm
[ __ ] 40 different stimulants oh just
with third eye fifth eye
seven eyes just [ __ ] ew
oh he dropped a [ __ ] chakra the other
day i was walking behind him and a
chakra fell right out of his pocket oh
my gosh and i had to pick it up and give
it to him dude i've different times yeah
i caught him in the bathroom and his
body was full on from the movie cocoon
when it was all gold and shiny and you
have to like look away yeah and he was
like oh and then he pulled his pants and
i was like what the [ __ ] dude and he
just floated away through the wall yeah
he's got that right yeah
he's got power oh i saw him wait sorry
yeah i saw him eating owl nuggets bro
straight owl oh dude 100 pure owl
nuggets eating him out of a [ __ ] bag
uncooked dude that's what he does man i
saw him the other day he was backstage
comedy store eating ferret sashimi oh
yeah dude i was like well that's not
even a food he's like yeah i killed it
with a crayon yeah
what the [ __ ]
dude he had a [ __ ] quart a fresh
court of moon glow bro oh my god yeah
just iridescence off the [ __ ] moon
bro yeah oh jesus non-liquid base he
told me i'm like what dude no rules like
i saw him take a grenade that was just
filled with soil and just swallowed it
and [ __ ] detonated it and it was just
pure soil from egypt i don't even know
if they have soil and it just detonated
and then all of a sudden
it's a lab workout yeah his whole abs
were like perfect and then a [ __ ] a
golden cat ran out of his [ __ ]
it doesn't play where was that locally
dude that was right in the middle of the
405 freeway oh my god man yeah i was not
see those he does some of his best work
on the 405. yeah no he's ledge wait who
was from uh oh i saw him suck the cystic
fibrosis right out of a kid once oh my
god
he is a healer too were you a class clan
i was but just verbally i didn't do any
you know i wouldn't you know doing
anything physical
what do you mean i would just verbally
say something like you know
like somebody like my mom died like the
teacher one time was like my mom died
you know and i was like prove it you
know
but i would never get up and like
you know juggle or show my [ __ ] or
like that yeah well class clowns i don't
know if showing your [ __ ] when we
were kids when i mean i've got some
years on you but generationally speaking
when we were younger it was okay to get
up stand in your desk and show your
[ __ ]
that would have been funny now you're
going to have problems because it's just
a much more peaceful we had to do mr
patrick he would for he'd give you 20 40
bucks he'd walk about 60 feet from you
show you his [ __ ] as long as you
looked at it you kept the money
that's [ __ ] amazing you know and is
that
pedophilia i don't know what that is
that's art that's a new yeah that's kind
of art yeah that's an atm dude yeah
definitely
that's amazing that's ass to money dude
you know
but yeah and as long as he would only
look he'd kind of look back once to make
sure you were locked in dude and i
didn't feel like
you know i didn't like watching him take
his belt off but i didn't mind seeing
his [ __ ] from far away who gives a
[ __ ] it's just another man's [ __ ] at
that point back then pedophiles were
pedophiles oh yeah you knew if it was a
pedophile yeah they had a van they were
yelling them a pedophile yeah that's
right i'm a pedophile
bobby's one of the most entertaining man
that i've ever known
so i could easily see
why a woman would like him i like him
i'm not even a woman
so i could easily see if i was a woman
why wouldn't why wouldn't i still like
him i would still like him i think
i would not
i don't think i'd have sex with bobby i
would feel uncomfortable having sex with
bobby he reminds me of like kind of like
a um
but that's me i'm also a man
and he's neither one of us is a gay man
so i think what i'm trying to say is
that
i didn't think anything bad of you at
all i thought
oh wow bobby met this girl probably
online
you know because he doesn't go out and
do anything so that's the only reason i
thought that i thought either
that he must have met her online or he
got like a
i don't want to say like a postmates or
somebody got a postmates and you showed
up you know he got hella lucky off a
burrito like that's what i was thinking
one time we eat some acid and we locked
this big girl into a room at this party
and uh and we kept going in there with
[ __ ] pots of [ __ ] warm water
[ __ ] pouring it on i feel bad i feel
horrible dude i didn't look we was kids
and we're on acid dude
and then bro you can't tell me this
though when i'm straight you gotta tell
me how mushrooms you block the girl i
just remember how old were you i just
remembered it probably 16.
that's terrible i know but here's the
thing let's say i was 14 that way it
makes it sound nice
but look she were a no she ate acid with
us bruh
she ate acid with us dude and what
happened was and we kept going in the
room with like these pots of warm i
don't know why we had the pots of warm
water because i think we just [ __ ] up
dude and we like pour a little on her
but not like torchy she wasn't in a cage
or not she was just you know free range
in this room right
but i think she was scared to come out
and one time we went in bro we heard
this loud sound and we went in and she
she had ran against one of the walls so
hard
had [ __ ]
moved the entire wall in this house dude
huge girl about 240 pounds beautiful
girl too
the most beautiful
biggest girl that i've ever known oh my
god like a dateline for this complete
[ __ ] ways that people died you know
people were wondering what was up with
nathaniel right and the thing was just
been at his house for two days he just
choked on a cool ranch to read you know
oh dude we used to have a lot of gays
would meet up behind a rest area bar in
our town you know because i grew up
across a river from a rest area uh-huh
and i don't have rest area in canada
rust area in america it's where you stop
on the interstate to [ __ ] truck
drivers yeah drugs kill a spouse leave a
kid you know what i'm saying it's
basically
it's like a halfway house but it's
unincorporated you know
and that's a good way to describe they
had a lot of the gay you know homoerotic
men sorry we'd meet up behind there and
do drugs and start touching each other
not even necessarily homosexual just
homoerotic yeah because
a lot of this was drug induced yeah it
was a guy like dale fuzz he gets a bunch
of those like spanish fly or [ __ ]
stay up all night baggies at the gas
station and then pretty soon fuzz is
like you know
and uh dude i met a girl in miami over
by joe's crab shack and bought nine of
those gas station you know dick pills
that's when they first came out
bro couldn't 1916. i couldn't bend my
fingers right
and my nose kept bleeding
jesus
dude and i was up all night didn't you
bend your fingers any of them and i
would go through each one and try to
bend them you're lucky to be alive that
is [ __ ] oh dude my nose was bleeding
i must have lost i don't know how much
you know how much blood i lost at night
but um but anyway but that was the first
time i've ever had snow crab i remember
that we had a question that came up uh
um
riley mal's here with us today
and uh
and why don't you bring something up
riley we got a fellow that from the mta
i know that brought in a question here
it's an urban gentleman kind of
suburban gentleman
no urban this guy's urban oh urban
gentleman
there we go get it out okay that's it
huh did you ever move back to kelly
well let's see what this guy has to say
[Laughter]
sorry brandon the bike the podcast is
off
it's just going to be some sting brandon
oh it's been staying for a couple weeks
over there
you and chris you better eat some weird
[ __ ]
hey what's on the menu what's on the
menu next week
they're probably getting freaking
ridiculous over there
dude i'm not flying like i'm flying in
for a delicacy
get out of here get the volume on riley
no hold on so you're not going back bro
you're not going i'm going back dude
[ __ ] you bro this is a question turn the
question on right i can't even throw my
mic because there's no phone coming down
fix
i couldn't even throw my mic away
because y'all made fun of me for the way
i laugh on the podcast who did you shut
the [ __ ] up
that is you
[Laughter]
who said that who did that one
i did that's awesome bro
find a better way to fix it riley yeah i
know that's what i'm trying to do okay i
was crying sorry man this question was
probably all these kids you got working
here bro
like 12 years old
i don't know
it's getting bad got a little peter pan
factory going on
what's going on
that's the one thing you find out
outside of la in new york dude it's
young boys
we got a question dude your mic is
looking for you bro
it's just getting further
the other day you might put up a wanted
poster to victory you want it bro
have you seen
it's just you in the picture you're
hanging in front of me somebody gotta
prank me where they just like cement it
in i go to push it away
it's the new shake weight
god i'm sure
he did 212 mics today my question is
what the [ __ ] size of that bed and how
does he really sleep on it it is a
smelly tongue
is it a toy yeah look how there's only
eight little bars going across it looks
like the pen baby yeah that is a very
lean bed this could be a the oldest baby
i've ever
seen i remember one time we uh
this uh
um
[ __ ] uh you got me out to death for you
i'm gonna be the dead
i'm gonna
[Laughter]
of opiates for pain has decreased
substantially and the crime rates have
gone down interesting well still people
stoned on pot it's hard to pick
somebody's pocket yeah break into a
building i don't think so
you're just not going to get it together
you might knock for a long time i think
you might knock at the front door i
don't think you're gonna break in you're
not gonna you might that's right you
might knock you're not gonna go out what
are you gonna go in the alley and have a
fight no you're not a real slow fight
well while you're watching your hands
like yeah so it's like chest with your
hands exactly exactly that's not gonna
happen was there ever a time where there
was i heard like rumors and stuff that
there was a time where some of the
reindeer wasn't
you know there was like some of them was
kind of struggling doing you know not
drugs but like just struggling with
stuff that they were going through was
there ever a time where they were going
to replace some of the reindeer
well we're always have reindeer in
training okay
for example this year i've got two
reindeer
that are hoping to make santa's reindeer
team next year and their names are holly
and jolly oh really oh yeah
okay they're working hard a couple max
preps out there i like that so they're
kind of on the uh junior varsity right
there on the junior varsity that's right
we had a dude who used to give you he
had like just he'd always have raisins
in his pockets individual raisins and
he'd give you a couple of them we had a
dude my dad had a friend
and uh he'd put cinnamon on the [ __ ]
palm of his hand and let you lick it off
and this was probably
and one of his feet was longer than the
other one or he had a what the [ __ ] is
the
extra foot or not he was black where he
had like half of an extra foot so you
know throwing out the bottom of it well
black people are always trying to show
off you know but he had like a no hold
on a second
he had like a lift on his shoe one of
his feet wasn't that long oh one of his
feet oh i thought you meant he'd had
like two feet stacked like a sandwich no
like a foot sandwich with no crazy
he had a bread sandwich he had a
two-story foot yeah two-story foot
oh my goodness just a stack just a big
mac foot
um
two patties
my favorite drink
probably
cocaine i think
[Music]
[Music]
you